Another goal of the internet was distributed management.
And there are many examples where distributed management
has played out. In addressing, we have routing
registries. For example, in North America we have
ARIN, or the American Registry for Internet Numbers.
And in Europe that same organization is called
RIPE. DNS allows each independent organization to manage
its own names and BGP allows each independently
operated network to configure its own routing policy.
This means that no single entity needs to be
in charge and thus allows for organic growth
and stable management. On the downside, the internet has
no single owner or responsible party. And as
Clark said, some of the most significant problems with
the internet relate to the lack of sufficient tools
for distributed management, especially in the area of routing.
In such a network where management is distributed
it can often be very difficult to figure
out who or what is causing a problem
and worse, local action such as misconfiguration in a
single local network can have global effects. The
other three design goals that Clark discusses are
cost effectiveness, ease of attachment, and accountability. It's
reasonable to argue that the network design is fairly
cost effective as is and current trends are
aiming to exploit redundancy even more. For example, we
will learn about content distributions and distributed web
caches that aim to achieve better cost effectiveness for
distributing content to users. Ease of attachment was
arguably a huge success. IP is essentially plug and
play. Anything with a working IP stack can
connect to the internet. There's a really important lesson
here, which is that if one lowers the
barrier to innovation, people will get creative about
the types of devices and applications that can
run on top of the internet. Additionally, the narrow
waist of IP allows the network to run
on a wide variety of physical layers ranging from
fiber, to cable, to wireless and so forth.
Accountability, or the ability to essentially bill, was mentioned
in some of the early papers on TCP/IP but it really wasn't prioritized.
Datagram networks can make accounting really
tricky. Phone networks had a much easier
time figuring out how to bill users. Payments and billing on the internet
are much less precise and we'll talk about these more in later lectures.